when we think of military interventions
in the cold war it's often those of the
superpowers
such as the usas in vietnam or the ussrs
in afghanistan
yet one nation which maintained a
long-standing military presence in
another country was cuba
whose troops stayed and fought in angola
for over a quarter of a century
but why so the first question is why
angola
well as many of you will know it used to
be part of the portuguese empire as of
the late 20th century that empire wasn't
doing all too well and the people of
angola were fighting to get rid of the
portuguese
the two main groups doing this were the
mpla who were communist and junita who
were not
in 1975 the portuguese announced that
they were going to leave angola forever
which meant it was civil war time prior
to independence the cuban government had
supported the mpla by providing some aid
in the form of military attaches and
doctors
it didn't send any overt military
assistance since that could risk war
with portugal but when they had left in
the civil war had begun the cubans had a
much freer hand
their reason for such involvement was
ideological cuba wanted there to be more
communist states in the world and unlike
the ussr's leadership fidel castro
believed that africa was particularly
well positioned for communism
another question some might be asking is
why specifically angola are not
somewhere closer to home
it was a literal ocean away and there
were other much closer fights involving
communists that cuba could help with
and the reason they didn't was because
direct involvement in south or central
america would provoke the ire of the us
and was best left to the soviets whereas
the fight in angola was far enough away
that the us was less
interested in direct involvement that's
not to say that the u.s wasn't
interested in angola it was
but matters were complicated when the
war spilled over to neighbouring
countries and eventually invited the
attention of south africa
south africa which was trying to
suppress an independence movement in
namibia sent troops into angola in late
1975 to stop aid coming from the north
and also because they didn't like
communists
the mpla didn't fare too well against
south africa's troops and so castro
decided to directly intervene
and at this point the angolan civil war
largely became a proxy war between south
africa and cuba
south african involvement did make
intervention by the us much more
difficult since apartheid was not
popular internationally and so the us
directly aiding the country enforcing it
was not a good look
after a couple of years angola proper
was mostly secured and south africa had
retreated
the civil war expanded again and in 1983
south african troops returned to aid
unita
and cuba responded to this by sending
tens of thousands of its own soldiers to
angola
years of continuous fighting culminated
in the 1987 battle of quito cuaneva
which was the decisive mpla cuban
victory
and after this angola south africa and
cuba decided to negotiate because this
war was getting expensive and also
south africa was losing here it was
decided that the mpla would be the ones
to run angola south africa would leave
and cuba would withdraw its military
forces
direct foreign involvement in the
angolan civil war was now mostly over
and cuba had achieved the long-term
changes in angola that it wanted
for about a year when the mpla dropped
its commitment to communism but still
a good effort i hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
a special thanks to my patrons
james bissonette sam kelly moneymaker
the pastry section danny maloney moe
marvin cassal rob waterhouse james
castaneda jordan longley spinning three
plates gustav swan jerry lamdin rasheed
ali marcus asner izzy maggie paxkowski
cooling castleman david silverman copper
tone anthony beckett matthew shipley
lexi schwinn robert wetzel skye
chappelle winston k wood aaron the white
spencer lightfoot and fobo joe